measuring a Quantum superposition is as random as flipping a coin but how far can we take that
analogy before it breaks down we'll find out today on kiss in the
classroom welcome to kiss in the classroom a video series where we break down a fundamental concept that you
might encounter in a Quantum Computing related course each video is accompanied by an interactive module Linked In the
description below so be sure to check that out today we're talking about one of the core principles at the heart of
quantum theory superposition in our everyday experience objects always have definite features their location size
shape color everything about them is determined and certain even if we The Observer haven't yet measured it in the
quantum world this isn't necessarily the case a Quantum object can be in something called a superposition of
multiple class Al allowed states which when it's measured will randomly collapse to one of those
States measuring a superposition state is like flipping a coin there's no way to know ahead of time which way it'll
land this fundamental indeterminism is an uncomfortable aspect of quantum mechanics that even Einstein had trouble
with he famously said God does not play dice about this Randomness but as we'll see God in fact does play dice or in in
our case he flips coins but what's more these coins are loaded measuring a Quantum superposition may be similar to
flipping a coin in some ways but the superposition itself is much richer and more complex than a classical
probabilistic state to see this we're going to think about how a classical coin works and contrast this with our
Quantum coin that we'll explore using kuit on an IBM quantum computer first a classical coin it's
pretty simple you toss the coin and it lands either heads up or heads down with 50% chance of each well in principle we could
calculate which side the coin will land on if we knew the precise initial conditions of the coin and exactly how
much force and torque were applied during the flip but in practice there's no way to know a priority which side the
coin will land on that's why we use the coin flip as a canonical example of a classical probabilistic state where the
outcome is essentially random if I were to flip this coin a thousand times and record the number of heads up
and heads down I would get a histogram that looks something like this so we have counts on the Y
AIS and it could be either heads up or heads down and the
histogram would show that there is about 500 counts of each up to some
statistical fluctuation we can create a similar State using a cubit on our quantum computer like the coin flip a
cubit can also be measured in two possible States zero and one if we apply something called a hadamar gate to the
Cubit it'll put it in an equal superp position of zero and one here's a
visualization of that circuit which we called a circuit diagram here the top wire is the
Cubit and the operations applied to the Cubit show up as boxes on the wires the hadamard gate is shown with this box
labeled H and the measurement is shown with this gray box labeled with the little measurement symbol it sends that
measurement to a classical bit this wire with two lines so since the Cubit is in an equal superposition of 0 and one when
we measure it there will be a 50% chance that we measure zero and 50% we measure
one we express this Quantum superposition State as s = 1 / <
tk2 0 + 1 / < tk2 1 where the squares of each of these
coefficients also called amplitudes are the probabilities of measuring each state so in effect applying the hadamard
gate is the analog to flipping a coin and just like we flipped the coin a thousand times to to look at the
statistics of the coin Landing heads up or heads down we can do something similar on KCET with our Quantum coin
we'll use a kisc primitive called sampler which will repeat the circuit several times to sample the statistics
of the resulting state with a thousand samples of the circuit above we have something that looks basically identical
to the classical coin histogram up to sum statistical fluctuation so is that it quantum
superpositions are essentially the same as a classical probabilistic State akin to flipping a coin not quite this would
be a pretty short video if that were the case to see our first key difference I'm going to try something slightly different with my classical coin instead
of Simply letting it fall onto the table Landing either heads up or down I'm going to toss the coin and catch it
midair between my Palms now the coin is not heads up or down but instead it's either heads left
or right so logic tells us that this two should have a 50/50 probability of being
either heads left or right to measure heads left or right on our Quantum coin we can do what we did with the classical
coin measure along a different AIS our standard measurements on the quantum computer are along the vertical axis
just like the usual heads up or down measurement of the classical coin but we can also ask our Quantum coin if it's
heads left or right we call the these two states along the xais plus or minus
for this we use the kcit Primitive called estimator to complicate things a bit instead of returning a histogram like
sampler does estimator will instead give us the so-called expectation value of any observable of the Cubit to
understand this expectation value let's say you get a dollar every time the coin lands heads up and lose a dollar when it
lands heads down the expectation value is how much money you can expect to earn on average with each coin toss since
you're equally likely to gain or lose a dollar the expectation value would be zero the same reasoning can be applied
to the Cubit when we find the expectation value of x when we apply x to the plus State we
get the value + one and to the minus State we get minus one so if we had a
50/50 distribution we would get an expectation value of zero but we don't we get an expectation value of plus one
meaning the coin is always measured to be plus along the x-axis that would be like flipping a
coin clap catching it and guaranteeing that the head would always be facing to the right this is because a
superposition is not just a probability distribution remember how we express a Quantum
State s is equal to C 0 * the state 0 plus C1